Kim Kardashian will continue to lay low
following her Paris robbery this
according to a source who tells ET the
reality star needs a break from
everything quote working and posting on
social media is the last thing on her
mind right now she canceled her meetings
and work commitments for this week our
source says Kim it doesn't necessarily
think flaunting her jewels on social
media led to the robbery but doesn't
realize it may have been a factor so
don't be surprised if Kim starts posting
it less moving forwards whoa do you will
definitely see a difference with that in
the future from the whole family came it
seemingly hadn't left her New York City
apartment since arriving back in the US
on monday until thursday when she was
spotted sneaking out with husband Kanye
West and their children our source says
the mom of two is focused on spending
quality time with kids north and st. who
don't know anything about what happened
and she's trying to stay strong for them
quoted she still gets emotional thinking
about the incident she tries not to cry
in front of North but it's been tough
you